ein einzelnes militärhistoriker an der
uni potsdam er befasst sich intensiv mit
diesem konflikt und auch mit möglichen
lösungen dafür guten abend und
willkommen zurück im heute-journal der
professoren gute nannte sie was ja
gerhard schröder hat gesagt die gute
nachricht heißt der kreml will eine
verhandlungslösung haben sie denn heute
von schroder etwas gehört von dem sie
sagen das wäre ein ansatz für
verhandlungen
nein es ist sicherlich auch falsches von
schröder von vornherein in bausch und
bogen zu verdammen da gibt es ja auch
reaktionen und muss nur in ruhe sich
dieses interview durchlesen sehen was er
sagt aber aus meiner sicht ist da keine
substanz drin denn was schröder
vorschlägt ist ja ihr könnt man könnte
sich einigen auf die anerkennung der
krim auf eine kantons lösung im dom bars
mit sprachpolitik und auf
nichtmitgliedschaft der nato der ukraine
das sind ja alles punkte die vielleicht
nicht die uhr aber de facto russland vor
dem 24 februar vom westen hätte bekommen
können auch von der ukraine und deswegen
hätte putin diesen krieg nicht führen
müssen also ich sehe in diesem interview
eigentlich nur nebelkerzen und ihr kein
wirklich substanzielles angebot haben
auch im beitrag erwähnt auch dieses
rumgeeiere mit der gas pipeline und den
turbinen also damals meiner sicht sagt
schröder auch die unwahrheit und eben
dass putin eine verhandlungslösung will
wie schröders gesagt hat sie haben es
auch einen beitrag gesagt das sehe ich
so nicht schließlich hat lacht ja noch
vor einer woche gesagt dass die ukraine
zeigen wird sich ausgelöscht werden muss
wir dürfen auch nicht vergessen dass
jeden tag in diesen tagen vier bis
fünftausend granaten von der russischen
at&t abgeschossen werden auf ukrainische
stellung das etwa 30 ukrainische
soldaten jeden tag sterben also nach
verhandlungslösung sieht das nicht aus
als ergeben dass vielleicht noch mal ein
bisschen durch schröder sagt niemand
glaubt mehr dass ein russischer
präsident die krim wieder aufgeben
könnte da geht es ja in der tat eine
ganze reihe von menschen die ihm da
zustimmen würden oder ja da würde ich
eben auch zustimmen ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass ein russischer präsident
die krim wieder aufgeben würde ich sehe
auch nicht im gegenzug die militärische
fähigkeit der ukraine die krim
zurückzuerobern
wir diskutieren jetzt in der höchsten
kreisen ob es der ukraine vielleicht
möglich sein könnte den landkorridor
zurück zur oberen aber da gibt es ganz
viele fragezeichen aber für eine
offensive richtung krems nach meiner
einschätzung fehlen der ukraine jede
voraussetzung und dann müssen wir eben
unterscheiden was gibt es eine die jure
anerkennung die wird es nie geben aber
man kann sich eben auch mit der
normativen kraft des faktischen abfinden
wie ist ja der westen bei der annexion
der krim aufgemacht hat und darauf wird
es sicherlich hinauslaufen für den don
was eine art status wie den von
schweizer kantonen auch dass eine idee
von gerhard schröder was sagen sie dazu
also das ist ja nun völlig abstrus dass
keine einschätzung also putin wird ja
ähnlich wie die krim mit sicherheit
nicht dass
das gebiet wieder hergeben was er mit
den so viel blut seiner soldaten erobert
hat denken wir jetzt an an die
volksrepublik lohans also in das wieder
herzugeben und ursprünglich sah es ja so
vor dass man beide volksrepublik einen
teil der ukraine aber mit mit einer
sprachpolitik nach mit eigenen sprachen
und so also das kann ich mir überhaupt
nicht vorstellen sondern das maximale
ziel was ich für realistisch halte aber
nach mir geht es da nicht sondern es ist
ja der ukraine russlands ist dass man
vielleicht ein status quo ante erreicht
also die linie die es am 24 februar gab
aber selbst das wäre für die ukraine ich
glaube ich ein großer erfolg und ich
sehe überhaupt nicht dass putin bereit
wäre sowas zu akzeptieren dann gehen wir
erstmal ein bisschen weg von gerhard
schröder es ist ja generell so dass sich
viele menschen tatsächlich fragen auch
hier bei uns in deutschland wie lange
dieser krieg noch dauert ist denn eine
verhandlungslösung aus ihrer sicht
überhaupt realistisch auf absehbare zeit
oder vielleicht anders gefragt was muss
denn passieren damit eine
verhandlungslösung realistisch sein
könnte naja also kriege werden begonnen
weil die staaten meinen einem gegner mit
militärischen mitteln den willen
aufzuzwingen und kriege werden beendet
weil entweder das gelingt das mit
militärischen mitteln den willen
aufzwingen oder
weil man merkt man kommt damit nicht so
recht weiter die eigenen kräfte gehen
aus und man muss sich weil das militär
nicht ausreicht auf einen kompromiss
einlassen so und ich sehe genau diesen
zwang zur zeit nicht weder auf seiten
der ukraine noch auf seiten russlands
ich glaube nicht dass die ukraine glaubt
dass sie am ende ihrer militärischen
möglichkeiten ist ich sehe die hoffnung
beim ukrainischen generalstab zumindest
die landbrücke zurückzuerobern also
südlich sa branche und so weiter und ich
glaube dass putin zumindest aus seiner
logik der meinung ist er hat noch nicht
alle militärischen karten ausgespielt
das heißt nicht dass es nie zu einer
kompromisslösung kommen wird aber ich
glaube nicht jetzt da dran wenn wir in
einem jahr wieder reden ist die lage
vielleicht eine andere aber ich würde es
sehr unwahrscheinlich halten wenn im
verlauf diesen jahres man wirklich einen
einen stabilen waffenstillstand eine
irgendwie eine stabile kompromisslösung
erreichen würden ganz kurz noch herr
professor wenn ich sie darum bitten darf
was ist denn generell von verhandlungen
von vereinbarungen zu halten mit
wladimir putin können dass nach all dem
was wir jetzt erlebt haben verträge
seien auf die man sich dann auch
verlassen kann verlassen kann man sich
bestimmt nicht darauf aber es ist immer
noch besser als nichts das sehen wir
jetzt mit dem getreide verhandlungen ja
es ist nur ein schiff jetzt müssen wir
abwarten was weiterkommt aber auch das
ist besser als nichts also ich würde
immer argumentieren wir müssen die
diplomatie mit einbeziehen müssen alles
probieren was möglich ist aber wirklich
darauf vertrauen dass solche verträge
halten das können wir natürlich nicht
professor kein einzel uni potsdam heute
abend wieder herzlichen dank für ihre
analyse sehr gerne